[Musica]
progresso progresso è un termine che ha
origine latina viene dall'unione di due
parole pro che significa avanti e greco
che significa passo quindi il progresso
è uno spostamento in avanti e un
avanzamento è un'evoluzione ci sono due
tipi di progressi abbiamo il progresso
scientifico tecnologico che va alla
velocità della luce
direi oggi ma abbiamo anche un altra
forma di progresso che va a una velocità
un po più bassa il progresso culturale
il progresso morale il progresso sociale
eppure si tratta di due forme di
progresso che coinvolgono l'uomo sia il
progresso tecnologico e scientifico che
il progresso morale e culturale
perché allora c'è questa differenza
questa differenza di velocità nel
trasferimento nel passaggio bene il
progresso tecnologico e scientifico e
quello che si trasmette sui testi che
oggi si trasmette in rete immaginiamo
alla semplicità e alla facilità con cui
oggi è possibile reperire materiale
tecnico documentazione relativa a una
tecnologia un concetto a un teorema a un
assunto immaginiamo invece il progresso
culturale morale sociale che riferito
invece ad una sfera più intrinseca
all'uomo ad una sfera personale
beh questo sicuramente è più difficile
da tramandare è più difficile da far
concepire e percepire all'uomo
provate a immaginare i nostri avi
spostiamoci qualche migliaia di anni
indietro avrebbero mai pensato che la
cultura contadina le tradizioni
contadine la loro storia avrebbero
determinato avrebbero portato e
contribuito all'innovazione tecnologica
che oggi si sta facendo in quella zona
sicuramente no invece questo oggi
avviene
e sulla base e sulla convivenza di
queste due diversità che sono la storia
la tradizione la storia contadina e
l'innovazione tecnologica che si sta
generando progresso noi nella murgia
crediamo che nulla è impossibile a meno
che tu non pensi che lo sia e questo è
quello che sta accadendo nella nostra
terra una terra fatta di cevo di 2500
anni di storia e di tradizioni che
dobbiamo valorizzare che stiamo
valorizzando e che non stiamo
assolutamente contrapponendo
all'innovazione tecnologica
questo cosa sta determinando sta
determinando una diversità la diversità
quale abbiamo una zona dicevo con una
cultura contadina agricola nella quale
si fa innovazione tecnologica nel mondo
ce ne sono tante di zone in cui si fa
innovazione tecnologica ma noi abbiamo
questa unicità che la coesistenza tra
2.500 anni di storia e l'innovazione
tecnologica cosa che nelle altre parti
del mondo
in questa forma non c'è e di questo si
sono resi conto anche tutti quei giovani
che nel corso degli anni hanno cercato
in tutto il mondo zone in cui si facesse
innovazione tutti quei giovani che in un
mondo come quello di oggi in cui si
progredisce tecnologicamente e
culturalmente continuamente in maniera
così facile grazie appunto alle
tecnologie e hanno cercato in giro per
il mondo zona in cui poter fare
innovazione e le hanno cercate tutti
quei giovani oggi è come se la loro
terra
gli stessi richiamando offrendoli però
un valore aggiunto offrendogli la
possibilità di fare sì innovazione
tecnologica ma non solo di valorizzare
rispettare i 2500 anni di storia
crediamo fortemente nella filosofia cosa
intendiamo per filosofia il bill e il
benessere interno lordo
pensiamo che affinché questi giovani
sparsi nel mondo possano rientrare
e possano mettere a frutto le esperienze
che loro hanno fatto in giro per il
mondo ed è fondamentale metterle a
frutto non pensare che queste questo
nuovo queste esperienze vanno
contrapposte e contraddistinte rispetto
alla storia e alle tradizioni locali
no non vanno considerate in antitesi
questi giovani stanno rientrando nella
terna e la loro terra lavoro li sta
richiamando offrendogli l'opportunità
l'opportunità di fare innovazione ma di
conservare anche la loro storia il
progresso dunque prende forma nel
momento in cui ci sono delle diversità
nel momento in cui c'è una convivenza
tra le diversità quindi nasce dalle
diversità ma un concetto chiave è che il
progresso non deve per determinare
diversità e discriminazioni
il progresso deve essere progresso per
tutti per tutti intendo a livello di
genere a livello di ceto sociale a
livello geografico a livello di etnia
quindi neutralità in questo senso il
progresso nasce lì dove ci sono delle
diversità e c'è la convivenza tra le
diversità ma è per tutti non deve essere
discriminante le diversità dove sono
abbiamo abbiamo detto la storia quindi
il passato ma abbiamo anche il futuro
l'innovazione tecnologica abbiamo un
genere sud che viene comunemente
idealizzato come culturalmente ed
economicamente più arretrato ma abbiamo
un gene contrapposto ad un nord che
invece è industrializzato e più
economicamente voluto come vedete ci
sono una serie di diversità che
coesistono in un territorio e sulla base
delle quali si sta evolvendo il
territorio stesso il territorio stesso
sta progredendo il progresso quindi non
deve essere discriminante non dobbiamo
l'uomo non deve avere timore del
progresso
se io provo a guardare un attimo i
prossimi 10 anni forse dieci anni e
anche tanto provo a guardare
prossimi cinque anni ma io in cinque
anni vedo progetti di intelligenza
artificiale progetti legati all'analisi
di questa mole miriade di dati che oggi
riusciamo a recuperare progetti legati
ai social network progetti in
telemedicina innovazione pura in tutti
gli ambiti questo non deve significare
che prendiamo l'esempio
dell'intelligenza artificiale su cui
spesso ci si si dibatte sul rischio che
l'intelligenza artificiale possa
sostituirsi addirittura l'uomo è
un'assurdità l'intelligenza artificiale
ma nessuna nessuna tipologia di
tecnologia può sostituirsi all uomo
perché l'uomo a creare ea fare il
progresso per cui li dove l'uomo
riuscirà a programmare le macchine a
gestire il progresso e l'evoluzione
tecnologica ma non solo anche quella
culturale programmando le macchine
dicevo e mantenendole nel concetto di
neutralità
quindi non ci sono macchine donne e
macchine uomini non ci sono macchine del
nord e macchine del sud affinché l'uomo
continuerà a programmare le macchine le
tecnologie in maniera neutrale
il progresso continuerà ad essere
neutrale
e così come io nei prossimi anni tutti
nei prossimi anni
vediamo un progresso esponenziale
ho detto ho fatto riferimento a progetti
di intelligenza artificiale ma ce ne
sono tanti di progressi e il progresso
la velocità del progresso e mi riferisco
al progresso tecnologico che abbiamo
detto va la velocità della luce fa passi
da gigante e quindi immaginate in cinque
anni quante cose riusciamo a fare questo
non ci deve assolutamente spaventare il
progresso sarà neutrale
lì dove l'uomo che colui che genera e
gestisce il progresso lo manterrà tale
lo programmerà tale buon futuro a tutti
[Applauso]